Okay, we're going to get started
with today's NCBI minute.
Thank you for coming today.
Let me just put in a plug
for our YouTube channel.
If you subscribe to our channel,
you can get updates of all the
videos we put up on YouTube,
including other tutorials.
In terms of the format of this
webinar, our speaker today, Kim
Pruitt, is going to be showing
you some slides about
updated prokaryote genome annotation.
If you have questions during
that, go ahead and put those
into the question pod.
Some of those could be
answered while Kim is talking.
Others we may answer when she
is finished with the slides.
Kim will answer those.
And others yet, we will put in
a document on the "Courses and
Webinars" page at NCBI under
"Materials" where you can see a
log, more or less, of the
questions and answers.
These slides today are already
up on this materials link at the
bottom of the slide
you're seeing right now.
That goes to the NCBI FTP site.
So without further ado, I'll
introduce Kim Pruitt to talk
about updates to prokaryotic
genome annotation.
Okay, thank you everybody.
I'm Kim Pruitt, and I'm the
person who is in charge of
RefSeq karyotes and prokaryotes.
And if you're not familiar with
RefSeq, in a nut shell, it is an
NCBI project to provide
reference sequence standards
that incorporate current
knowledge for genomes,
transcripts, and proteins.
It's a very large dataset, but
today I'm going to talk to you
about some of the new features
in our prokaryotic genomes.
So just to get started, I want
to give you a sense of how we
create our genomic records.
These are made basically from
the submitted data that's coming
into GenBank or our partner
databases in the INSDC, which is
the International Nucleotide Sequence
Database Consortium, or
Collaboration.
So you as the submitter
community do a lot of work to
generate genome sequence data
and to assemble that
into the genome sequence
that is submitted to NCBI.
In some cases you're annotating
that data yourselves,
or you're taking advantage of
NCBI's genome annotation service
for prokaryotic genomes.
All of that information gets
submitted to GenBank, and it's
available in our nucleotide
and protein resources.
Sometimes the raw data
is available in SRA.
The information about the
assembly itself is available in
NCBI's assembly resource, and
metadata about the sample that
was used and about the specific
research project are available
also in our metadata databases.
The sequence data and the
assembly information is then
copied into the RefSeq project,
where we are then carrying out a
whole genome annotation process.
This is something that
has changed recently.
In the prokaryotic world we used
to propagate annotation from the
submitted GenBank entry, and
only annotate those that did not
have any annotations, but now we
are annotating all prokaryotic
genomes using our
annotation pipeline.
This offers us a lot of
improvement in terms of
consistency of the annotation,
and in terms of being able to
update them in a more
timely fashion, because some
submissions come in and they're
never updated further to reflect
new information, and so in our
pipeline we can do those kind of
updates.
So I'm not going to go into the
details about our pipeline on
the previous slide that I'm
sorry I moved away from too
quickly.
There was a link to find more
documentation about the pipeline
process flow itself.
So our management of the
proteins that we annotate on
prokaryotic records has changed
significantly in the past couple
of years.
The original model that we were
using was that for any given
assembled genome, and so the
accession prefix is on the top
are two of the accession
prefixes that we use for genomic
sequence records.
For any given genome, we used
to provide a distinct accession
number, which I'm showing here
with a YP accession prefix, for
each annotated coding region
on that genomic sequence.
So the little pinkish boxes
are coding regions, and the
individual accessions would
be applied per genome.
So if you had two isolates of
E. coli from two patients in a
hospital, we would be providing
separate accession numbers for
both of those, so there was no
way to correlate easily that
the sequences were actually
identical at the protein level,
and we were having a huge
increase in redundancy
in the RefSeq dataset.
And so we undertook a massive
shift in our data model to
address the redundancy issue.
We went through an intermediate
stage where we had our original
accession numbers cross linking
to our new truly non-redundant
RefSeq protein dataset,
and these currently have an
accession number prefix
that begins with a WP.
So if you see an accession, WP,
followed by underscore, you know
you're looking at a truly
non-redundant RefSeq protein
record.
Our current model, which is the
completion of our transition in
our protein management, is
that all of our bacterial and
archival records are directly
annotated with the non-redundant
protein record.
So what this means is, for a
given CDS, let's say the first
one on my picture here, if this
protein is identically found in
five other genomes from the same
or different species, then we
annotate all six of those
genomes with the exact same
accession number, so there
will be six genomes that are
providing cross-references to
this identical protein sequence.
So we've significantly reduced
the redundancy in our protein datasets.
You can see some of the actual
measures of that redundancy in
our documentation page.
The link is shown at the bottom
of this page, where you just
plug in the NCBI root URL here.
So this offers us some
advantage in terms of redundancy
management, but it also has
had a very positive secondary
benefit in giving us a really
good way to manage protein
names.
We can now manage protein
names directly on this level of
non-redundant protein records
without having to re-annotate
the genome.
We can update the protein record
to offer an improved protein
name, and that improved protein
name is automatically propagated
to the Genome set that protein is annotated on, and this is a
really strong advantage
to this data model.
Along the way, we've also added
some categorizations to RefSeq
prokaryotes, so we now
categorize them as reference
genomes.
We have a small number
of reference genomes.
These are the highest quality
complete genomes that are
supported by curation, either at
NCBI by NCBI staff scientists,
or through communities
that we collaborate with.
So there's greater confidence
in the sequence of these genomes
and in the annotation on these
genomes, and I'm just giving you
an example.
Here in my examples, in all
three cases here, the first
identifier is to NCBI's assembly
database where you can get
metadata about the
quality of the assembly.
The second identifier is the
RefSeq genome accession number,
and then followed
by the species name.
We also have a category called
"representative genomes," and
what we're trying to do is
select a representative per
species.
Most of these representatives
are high quality complete
genomes, but some of these are
draft, and what we're trying to
do is select the best genome
available at this point in time.
These are subject to change
over time as we get more genome
sequencing data.
And for lack of a better word,
we're currently calling the
remainder our "variant genome."
The majority of these represent
bacterial species for which
there have been thousands and
thousands of sequences
submitted for the same organism.
So we may have thousands of
E. coli genome submissions,
thousands of salmonella genome
submissions, and these are
really defining variants of the
species.
You can find information about
these categories referenced or
representative by searching
our assembly resource, and here
is an example query to find
RefSeq reference genomes.
So this is a picture, a screen
shot of one of our non-redundant
protein records, and you can see
it has the WP accession number
showing up here on the record.
I want to point out that these
records are annotated at the
lowest common denominator
in terms of what organism
information they carry.
So if there is a -- in this
case, this is an extreme case,
this is something that is
annotated on genomes of
different species, where the
lowest common denominator of
those species is bacteria,
and so that is the organism
information that is carried
on this sequence record.
You might find others that are
carrying organism information at
the level of the genus, and, of
course, there are still many that
carry organism information
at the level of the species.
There's more information about
the non-redundant protein
sequences available online, and
at the top of the page is the
URL to that documentation.
At the bottom of the page is
the URL to the specific protein
record that I'm
showing you here.
Very recently we've added a
database that is being used to
manage protein names, and so
within that database we have
stored all of the protein names
that are currently used for our
non-redundant protein records.
We have stored all of
the Swiss protein names.
We are collecting and generating
a large dataset of HMMs.
We are doing protein clustering.
We are looking at identical
proteins, and we are curating
names.
And so we are embarked, in the
past couple of months, on a very
massive initiative to improve
the protein names on these
records and to standardize the
way we're formatting protein
names and these records, and so
you should look for improvements
to continue to come through
the course of this year.
And I can't spend too
much more time on this.
I think I'm over my webinar ten
minutes, but if you'll bear with
me for a couple more minutes,
this is a picture of a new
webpage display called the
"Identical Protein Report."
You can get to this from
any protein record.
There's a link at the top of the
page in the same location as the
GenPept FASTA graphics link,
shown here, to access this page.
This is a very useful page.
It tells you how many genomes
a given protein record was
annotated on.
In this case I've boxed three.
So this same protein accession
number has been annotated on
three different RefSeq genomes,
the accessions are shown here,
and the coordinates of the
annotation are shown here.
The organism information is
shown in the column to the
right, and so you can see that
these are three very different
bacterial organisms, and the
lowest common denominator for
these is at the bacteria level.
In some cases, this may be
an indicator that there was a
problem in identifying
the correct organism for a
submission, but in other cases
this is really reflecting very
interesting biology.
And last but not least, in the
process of converting to our new
data model, there was an
awful lot of suppression that
happened.
We suppressed the intermediate
level of records, the YP and NP
accession numbers on all of
our representative and variant
genomes.
I just want to make a note that
for the reference genomes they
continue to use the data model
where there is an independent
accession defined for those,
for the reference genome.
For those records that were
suppressed, we have provided a
custom message on those records.
So if you go to this URL, you
will see a very informative
message provided that tells you
that this accession that has
been suppressed has, indeed,
been replaced by a non-redundant
protein record.
And you can navigate to that
protein record to the identical
protein report or the
documentation about our "Me
Imitation Project." And last,
there is a comprehensive mapping
file provided for the those
who would like to have a
comprehensive report by FTP.
This file is available in
the RefSeq Release Catalog
Directory.
This was put out in the
beginning of this month.
In July, when we process our
next RefSeq release, this file
will be moved into the Release
Catalog Archive Directory where
it will continue
to be available.
This file provides mapping
between the old suppressed
protein accession number to
the alive non-redundant protein
accession that is replacing it.
It also maps old locus
tags to new locus tags.
We had to annotate our genomes
with new locus tags because we
are now providing de novo
genome annotation for all of our
records, and there are some new
genes that are being called.
So we cannot rely on existing
locus tags that may have been
submitted.
It also reports information on
GeneID mapping for people who
are interested in that
information from NCBI's gene
resource.
And I would just like to thank
people who have done all of the
work on these changes.
If you have questions, you can
look at the online documentation
that I provided links
to in these slides.
You can also look at our FAQ
or you can contact us at either
info@ncbi or webinars@ncbi
to follow up with questions.
Thank you.
So the question is what is
the source of the annotations
qualifiers attached to the
annotation of non-redundant
protein entry, and what is the
procedure if I have a question
about that annotation?
So are you talking about -- I'm
not sure exactly what you mean
by qualifiers.
Are you talking about the
organism information, the
protein name, or something else?
Oh, the product, so you're
talking about the protein name.
So, initially the source was
what came in from GenBank.
NCBI have been working on
correcting clustering and naming
things that are similar by
homology for a couple of years.
In the beginning of March we
created this new name management
database that really gives us
a lot of power to improve our
protein names, and we have
already improved about 1.2
million protein names, and this
is an area that we are extremely
actively working on.
So if you have specific name
examples, then, yes, please send
them, or specific names that are
bad, then, yes, please send that
information to us.
We're very, very interested in
improving the quality of the
names on our non-redundant
protein records, and you can use
the info@ncbi e-mail
to contact us for that.
Okay, that looks like
all of the questions.
If you think of something else,
go ahead and send those to the
webinars@ncbi e-mail address,
and we'll get those included in
the documentation
for this webinar.
Thank you very much.
We're going to sign off now, and
we'll see you at the next NCBI
minute.
Goodbye.